all right Jessica Jessica where you from
originally IE Inland Empire yeah tell me
about your uh family growing up you had
mom and dad I had a mom um I have a dad
but he's not always there um my mom
wasn't always there either so I had
grandparents you raised mostly by then
uh for the majority of my childhood yeah
what was mom doing mom was running the
streets she was into um
drugs and didn't want to be a
mom my dad what was your relationship
like with your
dad
uh it was good you know for the most
part but when I got pregnant that's when
we stopped talking we kind of had to
fall
out how many kids do you have at five
you have five mhm you're young how old
are you I'm 40 you're 40 mhm
who's raising your
kids my oldest daughter is right
now she has them back to your childhood
what uh how would you describe
it in general
um in general it
was I pretty much did what I wanted to
do I didn't have like a lot of guidance
really a lot of
freedom yeah I was spoiled by my
grandparents but I mean they were older
so they couldn't just like come out
looking for me and Chase me down my mom
she when I was with her she you know had
her own life she had her own friends so
she didn't really pay much attention and
my dad he was the strict one though he
was the one where I had to stay in the
house I couldn't do nothing so I didn't
really try to be there a lot no abuse
nothing no traumatic events um I was
molested when I was younger um my mom
left us me and my sister with um her
friend and her friend's boyfriend he he
molested us um that's how I ended up
staying with my grandparents and when I
was 12 I got
raped you feel like
that affected you in any way as you got
older um being molested yeah I mean it I
was young like really young like three
or four so I don't really remember too
much about it I just know that it
happened um being raped that I took it
as that was my own fault I I created
that to happen because I knew I wasn't
supposed to have nobody in the house
when my mom wasn't at work when she was
at work and I told him to come over so
if I wouldn't have been fast and told
him not come over then it wouldn't have
happened how far did you go to school I
went all the way up until the 11th grade
when I got
pregnant and I graduated when I was in
prison how'd you get into this kind of
work uh I had left my ex and well yeah
was trying to hide from my ex I was
trying to leave the relationship and I
needed some money so I could have a
place to stay you know I didn't have no
money he Froze all my accounts he turned
my phone off so I had to you know
figure out something how to do what I
wanted how to do what I had to
do so that's a quick way to make money
yeah you've been doing it now for how
long um about six
years you doing it on your own or do you
have
representation I don't like
representation I like to be an
independent
contractor you can keep your money that
way yeah you do I I don't like to ask
for
allowance what tracks do you work I
don't work on the tracks you work the
internet yeah internet you feel like
that's
safer yeah yeah I haven't had really um
no well I've had a couple bad
experiences but not like you would have
more on the the the
streets what have you learned about men
from doing this kind of
stuff really that men they can be really
really really out of this
world they are really something
else sometimes you would never even
believe some of the people some of the
guys how they really think in their
thought processes just
like kind of makes you want to go gay in
a
way like what in terms of their just the
fact that they're cheating on their
wives or girlfriends or or their
behavior the behavior their their
fetishes their thoughts the things that
they want these other they're into like
weird stuff yeah some really weird kinky
stuff I mean I get the fact that they
might not be you know sexually happy at
home with the wife or whatever you got
kids you know the day-to-day thing but
so I don't take it like oh cuz they're
out cheating on their wife like a man is
going to be a man he's going to do what
he wants to do
anyways so I mean it's sad to say it
that way but if you want to pay me to do
it then I mean hey I'm not going to turn
it down what's the strangest request
you've seen
the strangest request is uh I had some
guy want me to smash mice with high
heels on Smash mice like put them on the
ground put them on the ground and smash
them with my heels killing them
yeah paid me $2,000 to do it $2,000 mhm
and that was a sexual thing for him yeah
I think so I don't know what it was with
him but he got off on it I guess that's
that was his fetish
that's just cruel that's that's nasty
for mice it's nastier than I did
it hopefully some mice got
away no well I I I could only do one
like I couldn't do all of them that he
wanted and he got a little upset but I'm
not Walmart I don't give refunds so you
know you had to leave after that if you
didn't want to I couldn't do it it was
kind of sad it was hopeless that would
make you lose respect for men right away
yeah I did that I thought that was
really weird
you know doing this six years you're
basically a veteran
now do
you do you still view love the same way
that you did before you did this
work no I've never really viewed love in
a a good way really never don't think
I've ever had good love or a good love
relationship think I was looking for
love in all the wrong places and
definitely not going to find it
here
drugs are part of your
life yeah they are they they've been a
big part of my
life let me guess crystal meth
yeah what does crystal meth do for
you I don't even know really he doesn't
do much anything anymore I don't think I
don't even know why I get high just but
you're addicted you need it yeah I think
so it's what it is but getting high
isn't the downfall of my life or isn't
why I got brought into doing this it
just entices it a little
bit you get more money if you get high
the guys pay
more the guys basically want someone to
party with
yeah does your family know you're doing
it I mean I don't really have much
family the drugs are the prostitution uh
my um the drugs was no big secret they
know they know that the um prostitution
I mean I don't know if they know if they
don't know we don't never really talk
about
it my kids know I give money somehow
some way they just don't know exactly
how I get it you still talk to your kids
yeah I'm a big part of their life
they're they're a big part of my life
was there another life that you had in
your mind for your you know something
you wanted to do with your life rather
than this yeah I wanted to be an actress
when I was younger I wanted to you know
maybe write books or I was real creative
I like to do arts and crafts I like to
do different things I want to travel I
just didn't like school to have to go
through all the the learning of it
all where do you stay now are you on the
streets yeah right now yeah you stay in
a hotel
yeah how do you think this lifestyle has
changed you you've been doing it for six
years it's it it makes me not so naive
cuz I was naive a lot not a lot lot of
naive I didn't want to I always want to
see the good in people this life will
make you see the worst in people it will
bring out the worst of
everybody emotionally what do you go
through um emotionally I numb myself so
not feel
nothing to hurry up wham bam than you
put the money on the dresser and leave
like that type of numb most of your
interactions with guys are just get over
as fast as you can basically is the goal
yeah or try to yeah milk milk them for
more money yep I mean if you know if
it's an easy target then I mean I mean
why not try if I don't do it somebody
else will how are the different clients
you have different like white guys black
guys Mexican I don't I don't date um
black guys I won't date them most the
girls won't I don't know what that's all
about but well I mean I think it's more
less like with The Pimps because they
don't want the girls to fall under new a
guy but I don't deal with them because
they can get real aggressive and they
can they they don't like to pay they
like to jip you really they like to get
over on you so I don't that's why I
don't really deal with
them you think you get desensitized to
all the dangers that you go through you
know you're putting yourself in danger
when you do this strange guys come to
your room I mean I have a taser I have
pepper spray have you had to use them
I've I've had to use my pepper spray a
couple times yeah um
mainly like I usually they're usually
the guys that I I get off they're not
really that you know they they just want
to hurry up and wham bam and get go back
home they're going to get caught so they
um they don't really give me too much
problems your intuition get better yeah
I know the first five minutes of me
being in the room with somebody like if
it's going to be good or if it's going
to be bad I can sense
the you know if they don't want to give
you the money up front then I know it's
going to be an issue it's a just get
them out the room
now is it a lonely lifestyle for you
yeah it is lonely it it's only you um
sometimes you got to shelter yourself
away from everybody and things cuz it
will interfere with you getting money
you know and I'm the only one that if I
don't take care of myself nobody else
will so if I don't make no money that
day then how am I going to pay for my
room or how am I going to
eat what's the hardest part of this job
for
you uh the hardest part of this job is
dealing with different
men with your Chris meth addiction do
you see yourself getting out of here
somehow I want to I really do I don't I
don't want to be like this for the rest
of my life like I'm already halfway
through it but I I'm trying to I'm
trying to get out of
it what do you think most people don't
understand about girls that do this
work what they don't understand is
um that sometimes these girls have to do
it they have to do what they have to do
you know cuz they don't have nobody else
to to take care of them or they don't
have nothing or nobody once you get a
couple kids you don't have the father
just you know the father of the kids to
support yeah you know there's dead beat
dads then have to you know your kid
needs formula diapers and if this is the
fastest way to get it you have to do
what you have to do as a mother and then
you get addicted to the fast money then
you get addicted then that's when it all
goes downhill you get addicted and
caught up and every day is a different
promise oh I'm going to get out I'm
going get out or something better is
going to happen and you get more money
and then it's like okay well this is
better I'm going to stick with
this you have any
friends um not real one well I have I
have like maybe two or three two or
three real friends that are my real true
friends what advice would you give to a
woman who's thinking about doing this
kind of stuff find a different
job find a different Outlook in life you
give that advice but then you you're
willing to do it
yourself yeah cuz before if I had
somebody to tell me that I probably
would have listened I didn't have nobody
to tell me
that what your biggest
regret falling in love with the wrong
man yeah that's my biggest
regret Jessica what would you say is the
most important lesson you've learned in
your
life most important lesson
um you shouldn't let this lifestyle take
over your whole life to where you push
everything
away your kids your family what really
means the most to you who's really going
to be there for you at the end of the
day thank you so much for sharing your
story wish you lots of luck out
here